it starts with a yes or no question does
she have a crush on me will i pass the
test will the mets win the world series
while they may not have always predicted
the truth magic 8 balls are actually
inspired by a real-life clairvoyant
do you want to hear your fortune
in the 1940s mary carter was a popular
medium best known for her mysterious
fortune telling invention it was called
the psychoslate essentially a chalkboard
with a cover when the clients would
visit mary would ask a question to the
spirits
the room would fill with the sound of
scribbling and then just like poof magic
mary would reveal answers from another
world mysteriously written on the
chalkboard mary's son albert was
inspired by his mother and created his
own truth-seeking device but this time
you didn't need a psychic to tell you
your fortune
he put a pair of worded dice inside a
tube filled with molasses each end was
clear so you could read the answers
sound familiar
albert hit the streets he partnered with
a couple local businessmen and opened a
novelty company where they specialized
in the miracle home fortune teller after
he died albert's partners took over and
redesigned the project numerous times
they ended up with a crystal ball like
shape with a die in the middle and a
billiards company took note they needed
a promotional item so they replaced the
crystal ball with the iconic black eight
ball
the promotion was so successful that
they rebranded the magic eight ball this
time marketing it as a fortune telling
toy
today kids are still using magic eight
balls to ask for their fortunes and for
that you can thank mary the clairvoyant
ah yes